وفي المقابل اكد حاكم مقاطعه لوغانستان
على طول جبهات القتال مقابل تراجعين
للقوات الروسيه وتوجهها للمواقع الدفاعيه
واضاف المسؤول الاوكراني لاحدى القنوات
التلفزيونيه ان القذف الروسيه لا يتوقف في
عدد من المدن التي تمت استعادتها من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه في لوجان
بامكاننا القول ان الجيش الاوكراني حافظ
على كل المواقع التي حازها في محور كريمنا
القوات الروسيه الان في موقع الدفاع الى
شاك نحن مهضومه في تزويد جنودنا بكل ما
يحتاجونه واتمنى ان ازوف لكم اخبارا جيده
قبل نهايه العام في محور
الوضع تحت السيطره لكن المدينه تتعرض
اليوميا لقذف عنيف
مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر ومن خير سن مراسل
الجزيره تامر صمادي وابدا بك سلام خضر
وتصريحات من وزاره الدفاع الاوك الروسيه
عن قصف الاوكرانيه على دونات وايضا
بالطائرات المسيره
الدفاع يشير الى استمرار القصف العنيف
المتبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات
الروسيه منذ الصباح القصف لم يتوقف قبل
قليل سقطت عده قذائف اطلقت من الجانب
الاوكراني على حيث يتسكي في مدينه
والدفاعات الجويه الروسيه رصدنا عملا
مكثفا لها قبل نحو نصف ساعه يبدو ان كان
انها كانت تحاول التصدي لاهداف جويه
السلطات المحليه تتحدث عن اسقاط طائره
مروحيه تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه فوق منطقه
افديك لكن حتى الان ليس هناك من تاكيدات
بهذا الشان من جانب القوات الروسيه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تحدثت عن انها تستمر بصد
محاولات تقدم اوكرانيه خاصه جنوب منطقه
دونيت وقالت انها استهدفت عدد تجمعات
للقوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه في اكثر من موقع
جنوب دانيس دانيتسك او في خرسان
وزابولوجيا ايضا في هذه الاثناء يستمر
القصف لا ادري ان كنت تسمع زين اا حده
القصف المتبادل بين الطرفين ولكن بالعوده
الى ما قالته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه امس
كان هناك خبرا يتحدث عن تعرض منطقه
بالجراد داخل الاراضي الروسيه المقاطعه
الحدوديه الروسيه مع اوكرانيا تعرضت امس
لقصف اوكراني اليوم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قالت انها دفاعات الجويه الروسيه ام سي
اعترضت على الاقل اربعه صواريخ هارم
امريكيه الصنع كانت تستهدف منطقه الجراج
لكن القوات المضادات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت
هذه الصواريخ قبل وصولها من دون ان تعطي
معلومات عن ما هي الذخائر التي سقطت
بالفعل لانه هناك على الاقل ثمانيه جرح
داخل مقاطعه بالجراد في القصف الذي
استهدفها يوم امس زال
ابقي معنا اذا سلام خضر تمر صمادي
يعني وزاره الدفاع روسيه تقول انها قضت
على اربع مجموعات تخريبيه تابعه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه في محور جراس
نولمانسكار ايضا هنالك اعلانات اوكرانيه
على القذف الروسي والطائرات شاهد
الايرانيه ااا
لكن لا يعلن الاوكرانيون عاده عما يفعلونه
في الجانب الاخر لكن ما الذي يحدث عندما
محور الايمان
نعم القوات الاوكرانيه تحديدا هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن معارك طاحنه
في الحقيقه زين في مناطق الشرق عموما وفي
المنطقه التي اشارت اليها بالاضافه الى
محور باخموت ومحور ارضيات كالقوات
الاوكرانيه تقول بان مواجهات عنيفه مستعره
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه تدور على
الارض وانها كما تقول همم تكبد القوات
الروسيه هنالك همم يعني خسائر في العتاد
والارواح لكل روايته في الحقيقه زين في
الحرب ولا احد يتحدث عن خسائر بشكل واضح
خلال هذه المعركه لكن استطيع القول اسمح
لي ان اعود الى هنا الى خير سون بان القصف
لا يهدا لا يتوقف القصص طالما مركز
المدينه قبل قليل
كنا نحاول الظهور من هناك لكن الاتصالات
مقطوعه بالكامل في مركز المدينه والانترنت
ايضا خدمه الانترنت في هذا المكان الذي
اوقف فيه وهو في محيط الميناء النه خيرسون
لا يكاد يهدا القصف حتى يتجدد من جديد
تتحدث عن قصف بالمدفعيه الثقيله تقوم به
القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه الضفه الاخرى من
نهر دنبر التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
بالاضافه وانا اتحدث الان ايضا يتجدد هذا
القصف لا لا اعلم ان كنت تسمع زين ان كنت
تسمع الى هذا القصف من اكثر من جهه في هذا
المحيط كامل هنالك نعم هنالك قصف متواصل
ويتجدد مره اخرى يتجدد مره اخرى هذا القصف
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه
على طول ضفتين نهر دي نيبر بالمدفعيه
تتحدث القوات عن الاوكرانيه بالتاكيد عن
انسحابات لبعض الوحدات الروسيه من بعض
المناطق على الضفه الاخرى من النهار تحديد
النوبه
تتحدث هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه طيله
اليومين الماضيين عن توقعاتها بمزيد من
الانسحابات لالقوات الروسيه من الضفه
الاخرى لانها بتحديدا في من جهه خير تنقف
الاضافه الى زبروجا وذلك على يعني استمرار
القصف المدفعي الاوكراني لمواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه هناك والتطورات بالتاكيد
متسارعه همم في كياب في عديد المقاطعات
الجنوبيه حيث قالت القوات الاوكرانيه
بانها اسقط اسقطت اليوم بالفعل اكثر من 30
طائره من دون طيار من نوع شاهد الايرانيه
نعم